Former President Trump is
continuing his attacks
excuse me on his potential 2024
Republican rival,
and that is Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis.
Seniors Daniel Dale Fact-Check
some of Trump's claims about DeSantis.
So, Daniel,
let's start with his claim
that Florida is the third worst
in crime in the country.
Is that, in fact, true?
Well, there's a handy trick
for trying to make the country's
most populous cities and states
look like they're really bad on crime.
And that is simply using
their absolute totals
without factoring in their population.
So it is true that Florida has,
as former
President Trump said,
the third most reported
murders, rapes and aggravated assault.
What he didn't mention
is that that is largely
because Florida has the third largest,
most populous state.
And so if you look at per capita figures,
which is by far
the fairer way
to actually compare between states
Florida fares notably better it's
25th worst on murder.
So right in the middle
33rd worst unreported rape
so better than the middle
and 23rd
worst on aggravated assault again
right around the middle.
So very important context
that the former president
is not mentioning here
Daniel something
fascinating about the former
president is his ability
to meld recollections of things
like stories
change as he tells them more and more
and there's one
that he keeps telling about
yeah about how he only endorsed DeSantis
for governor
because he saw DeSantis
defend him
over his first impeachment battle.
Set the record straight on that one.
This is an easy fact check.
And the fact is, is
this could not possibly be true
because the president's endorsement
of then
Congressman DeSantis
for Florida governor came in mid 2018.
The Trump
first impeachment
battle began in late 2019
so he could not possibly
have seen him on TV
defending him on impeachment
and then said what the heck,
I'll endorse him for that reason.
Now it is possible
that Trump is thinking of DeSantis
defending him on the Mueller
Russia probe in 2017
but Trump is the one
who keeps raising Biden gaffes
as if
they're a sign of serious mental decline
or something like that.
So I think it's important to point out
when Trump's own stories are
similarly inaccurate.
Well, to be fair,
there have been several probes,
so one can understand
how you may confuse them
in what year they happen in.
Daniel Trump
also has been attacking
DeSantis over his pandemic policies.
And in a statement last week,
Trump claimed
that DeSantis
sealed all beaches and other places
for ended for extended periods of time.
Is that one correct?
This is an exaggeration.
So it is true that Governor
DeSantis closed some beaches in Florida.
He didn't close all of them in March.
20, 20.
He ordered the closures of public beaches
in Broward and Palm Beach counties, too
populous counties.
But he would not order
a statewide closure.
In fact,
he was sued unsuccessfully
for refusing to do a statewide closure
on the other beaches.
He simply order that people
limit their gatherings
to no more than ten people
and stay six feet apart.
And we know that was in line with what
then President Trump
and the Trump administration
were urging people to do at the time.
So the DeSantis
order certainly did
not come out of nowhere.
All right, Daniel Dale, keeping us honest
by always, fact checking everything.
Thank you so much.